I cannot believe it 13 years in the NFL
I know crazy Alex Smith here on the
Richard show it was 13 years ago where I
was interviewing though you post combine
yep yep you were I think you were you
were on satellite from Utah I guess
where and then 1313 crazy crazy you
played in the youth league 13 I don't
even know I don't even know how long for
you how long 15 15 right it's my 15 with
the NFL Network yeah we were you look
the same I don't look the same at all
you look like you have no miles trail
but at all yes you what what don't
how different are you as a quarterback
13 years in already different man yeah
yeah how I think so well you definitely
don't so I know it not only is a player
but yeah I think mmm-hmm how could you
not be I know right yeah I mean I the
crazy looking back this is the funny
thing I feel like you know 13 years ago
getting drafted as at that point that
was kind of the start of this whole
spread shotgun thing I felt like in
college football
yes known and obviously having a lot of
success in the college ranks but when I
got drafted you know still that stigma
of being a spread guy right can you be a
professional quarterback can you get
under center can you play in a pro
offense you know and no one ever what it
said 13 years ago right I mean it was
you can't run that stuff at the NFL and
now look at what now everybody look what
folks is getting running up like this
everybody's running it right all these
guys I mean you look at the guys and the
skillsets right from cam and Russell and
Mariota and all these guys that that can
do multiple things yes and so why
wouldn't you do multiple things with
them and I felt like I was kind of ahead
of that you know and so a little bit but
it's been somewhat it's been so cool to
watch that come back in or not come back
in but come into the league and really
because I feel like that suits my game
too right you know that I can do a lot
of different things so I would like to
do a lot of different things so I've
been fun to see that kind of creep in
what would you tell yourself back
combine the 13 years in Alex Smith what
would you tell that I stopped trying to
please everybody all right stop trying
to like impress and you know just I
a little more just be who you are
own it a little bit I mean I had to kind
of find out to write who I was and so I
had to go through that but who are you
pleasing back then I I just that
environment that whole combine this deal
it all it all breeds an environment of
right you have to impress right impress
and as a competitor right you want to
write a lot I think I'm the best I got
to put my best foot forward I got to
show this and right and then you do it
and then only getting drafted first I
felt like only made that worse because
then I all of a sudden you had you know
I obviously a lot of expectations a lot
of weight you know that I carried around
with me for for a lot of years would you
have preferred to not be drafted first
overall no I mean I think I had to I
think I had I needed to go through that
I think I had that anyway hmm I think
that only kind of I needed to go through
that as a person even not just as a
player I needed that but it was hard
hard at the time yeah like Smith here on
the rich eyes and shook care of FedEx
which we will hit shortly here on the
show do you think you've played your
last game no City Chiefs oh I don't mean
who knows I wasn't asking if you
returned 13 years no so I mean I played
long enough I've been through this
before I mean to tell you yes or no here
flat out either way would be lying I
don't know I love where I'm at I have a
year left on the contract but I get the
business I get tough decisions have to
be made so yeah I mean there's your
answer sorry no not at all but I mean if
is it something that you're you're gonna
do your best to control and I mean this
is he didn't roll it I mean I think
there you know I don't the nice thing is
I feel like I've been through so much I
don't get I don't worry about all the
stuff I can't control right you know I
have a year left so if there if there's
any control maybe maybe in that you know
that you know somebody if it does
happen that they kind of want to sign
you to some more years it's not just
that - it's also hey you know if they if
this does come to a conversation you go
to Andy who I'm sure you have a very
good relationship with right yeah I feel
like yeah been saying that right exactly
to be involved to be involved yeah to
say if you're gonna go somewhere else
then you you you do believe you've
earned that right yes for sure I feel so
I feel like and Andy Andy Reid again
with Doug Peterson now in this pepper
pole seeing this offense is there any
sort of similarities that you see some
of these plays that I know that I know
that I know that oh yeah quite a bit
like which ones I mean a ton of
similarities in fact I'd say more
similarities than not I mean I recognize
a lot of the plays so yeah it's fun to
watch though find it fun - I mean I'm
I'm pumped for Doug what he's done
pumped for Nick Foles you know he's good
buddy you played with him last year so I
mean what an opportunity what a job
they've done so yeah I hope open when
they pull it out now I'm keen to know
your thoughts on this subject do you
think Urban Meyer would want to coach in
the National Football League given an
opportunity I think it's always
intrigued him from day one always
intrigued him I think he could
absolutely well based on again what
you're talking about what's being
brought to the in the NFL from college
yeah and just being a leader that he is
I think he could no doubt I wonder
yeah I wonder if he still thinks about
it or not you know I know as a younger
coach he did you know with obviously a
lot in front of him I I wonder if it
still does so I'm wondering again I just
saw a couple years ago Bob Kraft
strolling around the horseshoe in Ohio
State year yeah and I'm wondering if you
know he's a savvy owner that if bill
ever decides to one day no longer want
to do it anymore do you think about that
idea I mean I like it I think that's a
good I mean there's some connections
there anyway you know I think Coach
Belichick and Irvin know each other well
they do a lot of history there between
those two I think similarities so I like
that if you could I would
while mr. Krafft up and well you for
that you also know why I'm I'm trying to
stir this thing up
I don't like it would be great to get
ribbon out of Ohio State it's been a
rough rivalry games for you guys lately
you know what I don't know why I even
brought that point up I should have just
kept you just opining about how urban is
it really wants to be a pro code just to
be fun it's been so fun to watch for me
to have played for both those guys you
know they played for urban and gym
that's wonder why do you stand on that I
can ask that a lot of a sudden I get
thrown in and now I'm in the Midwest I
get thrown into these big ten
conversations because you know having a
little insight so where do you stand on
that
where do you so I just root for a good
game Oh stick I mean come on
have a start bench bench or cut for Alex
man you ever start venture cut for Alex
Smith yeah all right you want to urban
meyer Jim Harbaugh Andy Reid start is
this this is like this is a game that
you have to start somebody up to bench
somebody have to cut somebody I like
that
do you because I'd like you to play that
game right those three yes you have to
start one
you have to bench one man a series you
have to cut one life's about making
tough choices Alex
that's dark venture cut with Alex Smith
what are you gonna buy playing an NFL
game or a college game moving mm-hmm see
that's it's a smart you know just in
life just just didn't like man as rough
yeah how about the vacation with bring
on vacation yeah it might be even
tougher
how about to bring on vacation I don't
think so that's not that bad okay start
venture cut to bring on vacation urban
March with them right and they have to
be on time they got to travel with him
he got to be around him you gonna eat
with them oh nothing against the other
tube no probably orbit you'd start urban
yes and you'd bench who who would you
bench just in case that Urban's not
available yes and then you cut one just
like we can't go on vacation together I
don't no one wants to go on vacation for
their boss
I'm definitely cutting Andy reading yeah
okay you're benching horrible on victims
media that playing star bench yeah what
are you doing with FedEx it investing
Wessel which is fantastic I'm I'm up for
the the FedEx air Player of the Year
great and so I think it's down to three
finalists so you got vote actually it's
on nfl.com slash FedEx so the FedEx is
gonna write a fifty thousand dollar
check to the USO under the winner's name
contest which would be cool but even
bigger so FedEx along in in partnership
with the USO this time of year the USO
does these football packages and FedEx
sends them to servicemen and women all
over the world to keep them connected to
back home friends and family and the
great game of football so cool to be a
part of you know it's awesome obviously
all of us are you know so thankful to
all the servicemen and women of course I
hope watchin and that's gonna be
announced in honors on and on Saturday
night all also along with the Walter
Payton Man of the Year award you were
the nominee for the Chiefs this year
let's talk before I let you go about the
Alex Smith foundation Alex Smith
foundation org what do you do in the
area in Kansas City and set this
foundation up yeah so we work with
foster youth that are either in their
teens or have emancipated from the
system this is basically when you turn
18 and substates is 21 and basically all
assistance ends a lot of these kids on
their own and and our main aim is to
help them stay in school and finish
school a lot of these kids as you can
imagine about half ever graduate high
school it's under three percent
nationally ever graduate college of
foster kids and and for so many reasons
as you can imagine being on your own
hard let alone trying to finish school
so yeah we just try to be that that
support we mean so many different things
along the way to help these kids like I
said just stay in school and finish
school I mean that's the main objective
and so run a program now in Kansas City
that's aimed at that and it's been a ton
of fun because I grew up with a great
family and great support that I still
lean on today and I'm 33 so I couldn't
imagine
and that when I turned 18 doing it on my
own and and I don't think it's fair that
we asked that of a lot of these kids so
just trying to try to help them along
the way good for you sir good on you man
Alex Smith foundation.org to get
involved on that and I would give your
Twitter address but yeah you don't do
any social media I don't I feel like I
kind of just missed that way if when I
came in you know me and I miss the way
the way is the way still there I know I
enjoy socially I socially just you know
[Music]
thing not even not even personal with
your family zero nothing I mean my wife
has one okay so that's it
okay yeah did you imagine the liberation
that would be just just the thought of
it is so freeing part of it to be honest
goes back to this whole just like not
it's good for me not caring like note
here and they hate oh here in the haters
and all that sort of crazy just any guy
I like you know yeah screw those people
well no I know that's what I'm saying
mama you know what I'm but you know
people want to know what Alex Smith is
all about who you know we knock on the
we've knocked on the door for you to
come on the show you know you know I'm
rolling
but again just a headline cuz we don't
want to treat him wrong normally we've
treat our guests basically saying Alex
Smith cuts Andy Reid but we won't do
that you just don't want to vacation
with your boss pretty much I mean Dan
Patrick told me I was going to the
Cleveland Browns so you guys have been
house how's that cool how that sit with
you like this thanks for coming on the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience